Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose
of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother,
Mary, and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep, and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine, will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never
swerve from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile
to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of resistance
in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother, Mary, to touch
my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
So this evening we're going to finish Volume 19 with God's help, and we're starting with
September the 12th, 1926, and this is an extremely important message, because the Lord wants
to tell us that He is forming eternal bonds with us in the divine will, and therefore
you take this bond with you on your journey home, it is eternal.
It cannot be changed, God is immutable, and what He decides is permanent, it's forever.
So Louisa said, it seems that my beloved Jesus comes back and I believe I will not lose him
again.
She said this so often, and then all of a sudden He escapes me like a flash, and I remain
without Him, without the one who forms the life of my poor existence with the harsh nail
of the delirium for the return of the one who makes the sun rise in my poor soul.
Now she has said that endlessly throughout these 19 volumes, and that's because she suffers
incredibly when it appears to her that the Lord has withdrawn.
So I want to give you Sam 63, my soul longs for you like a dry, weary land without love.
I also want to give you Sam 42, the Sam longing for the Lord's return, and she says that while
I was raving for His return, and I feared He might have left me all of a sudden He came
back and He told me, my daughter, don't you want to convince yourself that I cannot leave
you?
Now we've dealt with this over and over and over and over again.
If your union with me were bound, formed, and sealed on the basis of any other will
than mine, he said, you could fear, but since it is bound and written and signed on an eternal
basis of my will, what is eternal is not subject to mutations.
On the contrary, your whole being, your desires, your affections, and even your inmost fibers
are bound with eternal bonds, and my will flows in them to constitute itself their life and
to form them with the divine and eternal substance that it possesses.
Now what we've got to do is really look at that.
The message is simple, that if you truly are living in the divine will, and very particularly
as in Louisa's case, when the gift is confirmed, then you are bound with eternal bonds, and
that the divine will flows in every fiber of your being.
And so even a small movement, a look, a word, anything, everything is in the divine will
if you're at this particular stage, and the divine will flows in every single act and
move of the person to constitute itself their life.
He alone can make our acts eternal act.
He alone can make our acts divine acts because he is the divine and eternal one.
And since God is immutable, whatever he decides, whatever he does is eternal, and that's just
the way it is.
The biblical expression we have for that is carved in stone, you can't change it.
And so the divine will flows in each one of these acts to constitute itself their life
and to form them with the divine and eternal substance that the divine will possess us.
So God enters into absolutely everything.
I think it's absolutely extraordinary.
Our thoughts, our desires, our motivations, everything that makes us human beings.
He enters into everything, so it is a complete transformation.
It's really wonderful.
And he said, "Can eternity ever be split?
Can God ever change?
Can a supreme being ever separate from his own will?"
Of course, he entered all of that, as no.
All this is inseparable.
Now we know from about Volume 14 that the Lord has been telling Louisa that she has entered
into an inseparable bond with him.
It may have happened earlier, it's just that the discussion about it started later.
So Louisa is already in an inseparable bond with the Lord.
So he said, "How could I leave you?"
And she keeps on making the mistake of interpreting her emotional state as the Lord having left
her.
And that's an extremely important thing for us, the fact that I might be tired or that
I might be down on a particular day.
That does not mean the Lord has left me.
That is an emotional experience I'm having.
The fact that on a particular day I mightn't be able to pray as in feel that there is some
kind of bonding between me and the Lord when I'm doing the prayer.
That doesn't mean he's not there.
If I'm having a down day, does that mean the sun doesn't shine in the sky?
The sun shines in the sky independently of how I feel.
And the sun gives all of its wonderful effects to the earth regardless of whether you're
sick or well, old or young.
And so we need to understand this for ourselves because the Lord is trying to teach her.
She was the first on this journey and since she is suffering so incredibly, her emotional
state is very understandable.
So the Lord has to explain to her that disregarding how you feel, you are either in this bond
with the Lord or you're not.
So if we are in this living in the divine will, and of course most particularly if the gift
has been confirmed then of course your relationship with God is inseparable and indivisible because
you are transformed into light and light is not divisible.
In the same way everything that my will unites enters into the divine order.
You see your emotions are a bit like the weather forecast they can go up and down.
They can change, but anything that enters into the divine will enters into the divine
order, it's a completely different thing, completely different.
Because it enters into the divine order, it becomes inseparable from the divine one.
So how could I leave you if it were not so everything that my will has done in you,
it's crafting its foundation, it's very manifestations would be a game, there would be something
superficial.
It would only be a way of speaking, it wouldn't be reality and he's been telling her from
volume one that what he is doing in her and what he is doing through her is reality.
Therefore, he said remove these thoughts that I might leave you because it's not something
that my will produces or that belongs to it.
Now there's something very important there that you might skip over and that is our way
of thinking has to change and Jesus tells Louisa even at the height that she's at that
her way of thinking about this has to change because this is not God's way of looking at
it.
And we have to turn around and allow God to allow us to see as he sees, to perceive as
he does, to understand as he does, he alone can enable that, we can't be done on our level.
So if the divine will doesn't produce something, it doesn't belong to it and you have to put
in Hebrews 12, 14, without a holiness, nothing can enter the presence of God.
And so as we go on in this deeper and deeper and deeper commitment with the Lord, you find
that he tolerates less and less of the self or the old way of thinking or the worldliness
or anything else.
In other words, here is a very important point of discernment for us.
If we are years in the divine will, have I been transformed by it, am I a changed person?
Because this living in the divine will change us fundamentally.
So he goes on and he says, my will is firmness and indacelible bond.
In other words, it's immutable, it won't change.
It seems unseemly for one who possesses my will as life to occupy herself with anything
else that that's given as gently as possible.
And of course, it's given to Louisa because she's suffering so much.
But the Lord is saying to us, it is unseemly for one who claims to have this relationship
with the divine will, it is unseemly that we would occupy ourselves with anything that's
not him.
It is unseemly because we have entered into the eternal dimension.
Rather, you should remain firm that we would use the word steady.
You should remain firm on how to expand the boundaries of its kingdom so that it may triumph.
In other words, he's saying you should concentrate on this.
Try not allow yourself to be drawn into other reflections.
So this is massive mental discipline on our part.
Love the Lord with all your heart, with all your soul, with all your mind.
We find that rather difficult to give him all of our minds, to give him all of our way
of thinking, the pewteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
So you should be concentrating on expanding the boundaries of the kingdom of the divine
will because she was the person that the Lord wanted to use to do it.
So that it may triumph, that the divine will may be formed in you and that you may transmit
it to the poor generations as is 1926.
And there is a description of what society is like in 1926 and considering that we're
almost a century later, it's quite frightening how far we have fallen.
Watch this.
And you may transmit this to the poor generations which are now wriggling about and they are
forming the current of the chasms into which they will be swept.
In other words, here in 1926 you have already the actions and the movements and the thinking
and the decisions and everything that's happening that's going to produce the disaster of World
War II and the disaster that followed it.
What was wriggling about?
In other words, there's no steadiness there, there's no turning to God's will, there's
no wanting to even do God's will, they want to do their own thing and whenever we do our
own thing, it's usually a disaster.
But the chastisement also are necessary.
Now he's going to say something very interesting about the chastisements here.
Now he has said a lot about chastisements right from the very beginning but I just find
what he says here very interesting.
This will serve to prepare the ground so that the Kingdom of the Supreme Fiat may form in
the midst of the human family.
So we've seen from the earlier volumes that chastisements are used to try and shake people
up to put a correction into the system to try and bring people to repentance and all the
rest of it.
Here the chastisements and since this is 1926, you are talking about everything after this
will actually help to make the way for the Kingdom of the Divine will.
Now watch what's going to happen and of what I'm going to read now you'll find in the book
of Revelation.
So number one, many lives which will be an obstacle to the triumph of my Kingdom will
disappear from the earth that is straight out of Revelation 1118.
I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
So that has to happen in order for the Kingdom of the Divine will to really be established.
Now the second thing is other chastisements will be formed by creatures themselves.
So there will be chastisements from God, that's number one, that will remove the evil ones
from the earth.
And the second one will be chastisements that we have produced ourselves like the present
crisis that we're all going through, produced by human beings.
To destroy one another, it's happening as I'm speaking.
However, this must not worry you, he tells Louisa, because Louisa's job is to prepare
everything with Jesus for the foundation of this new Kingdom.
It's not to worry you, rather you have to pray that everything may take place for the
triumph of the Kingdom of the Supreme Feet.
Now I love that everything that must take place.
We've just been told about two of the everything that must take place and that is chastisements
from God, chastisements from human beings.
In other words, human race has actually got to suffer a lot to change its way of thinking.
Now we have a break and Louisa goes right into her rounds again.
First we have creation and then we have redemption.
So I became occupied with doing my usual round in the Supreme Will.
Now why is that given immediately after what we've just read?
It's because she was told that she was to get on with the work of preparing for the
Kingdom of the Divine Will.
She did it immediately.
She didn't wait.
She doesn't even tell us whether Jesus left or anything.
It's just the immediate obedience that I think is very interesting.
So I did it, she said.
So the light of the Divine Will made everything present for me, both what the Divine Will has
done in creation and what it did in redemption.
So there are the two fiats she was doing the rounds on.
The Divine Will by located in each act, by locating means that the Divine Will resides
in the most blessed Trinity and will also come into these acts as well.
By means to, locus is a place, so locate means to be in two places at the same time.
The Divine Will by locations in each act that it does in the creation and in redemption.
That's the them.
A weight is a little visit of mine to each one of its acts.
To be even a passing visit is very interesting now if you're busy.
Even a passing visit there where the Divine Will reigned and dominated the Queen to have
its little daughter as a company.
Oh, how it enjoyed my little visit in each one of its acts.
My little, I love you, my meager adoration, my gratitude, my I thank you and my subjection.
And since the Divine Will acts are innumerable, I never finished reaching them all.
It's not possible because we're just tiny creatures, okay?
But we do what we can.
Then as we reach the acts of redemption, my sweet Jesus made himself seen as a little
child but so little that he could be enclosed within my breast.
How beautiful, pretty, charming he was at to see him so little, strolling, sitting, placing
himself on his throne of majesty in my little soul.
Now, what she is being given here is a vision to help her to understand the spiritual reality
that she's dealing with.
So, she's allowed to see this picture of this miniature Jesus setting up his throne in her
heart.
But of course, that throne was set up in her heart in Volume 1 where she had three experiences
of union with God.
So he was setting up his throne of majesty in my little soul.
In other words, establishing the kingdom of the Divine Will as he has told her in the
last paragraph, administering to me his life, his breath, his act, so that I might take
everything from him.
He is our Redeemer.
He is the only mediator between us and God.
Everything is through him with him and in him and from him and everything else.
But while I could see him within me as a little child, at the same time, he also came crucified.
Now we have been told in all the volumes before now that every act of Jesus from conception
to his death, all these acts are available eternally because they were all Divine Will acts, okay?
So of course, he can appear as an infant and as the crucified one at the same time.
And she sees it so vividly that she notices the tension of his members that is as the
crucified one was that you could count all his bones and nerves, which of course is described
in Psalm 22 and in Isaiah 53.
She said you could count them one by one.
While the little child was enclosed in my breast, the crucified Jesus laid himself within all
of my members.
This is very important, okay, leaving not a particle of me that was not possessed by
his adorable person.
So he's taking possession, he's showing her what taking possession of her entire being
actually is.
She said I could feel his life in every part of her own and I want to give you for that
Colossians 1 24 to 26 because the Lord allows us to enter into his fashion with him to make
up for all that is wanting still in the body of Christ and the church.
In the next paragraph she says, "Then after I remained in this position for some time
with Jesus he told me, my daughter, my humanity possesses the kingdom of my will."
In other words, the Divine Will kingdom was established in the sacred humanity of Jesus.
So much so that my whole life was dependent upon the Divine Will and by being dependent
on it I had the divine intelligence, that's the intelligence of the spring volition.
He had the divine gaze, he had its breath, he had its operating, its steps, its motion
and the eternal heartbeat.
In other words, everything that made up the person of Jesus was Divine Will and he has
just laid himself within Louisa to illustrate what every part of your being becoming the
kingdom of the Divine Will actually is.
In this way he said, "I formed the kingdom of the supreme, fiat its life and its goods
in my humanity."
So Louisa has to do everything through Jesus with him and in him.
Do you see then what it means to form the kingdom in you and later in us if we get to
this stage?
I must transmit to you what my humanity possesses, which will administer to you its thought.
Now you remember at the beginning of this message Jesus had said to Louisa that the way she
was thinking was not exactly seemly for the Divine Will.
He's now showing her here that when he lays himself completely within us, he has to administer
his thought to us.
So we have to literally think not only through him, with him and in him, but think his thoughts
as well.
Let me put it the other way around to let him think in us, to let him speak through us,
to let him love through us and so on.
So the Divine Will must administer to you its thought, its gaze, its breath and everything
I possess for the formation of the kingdom of the Divine Will.
So you can see how much I love this kingdom.
I place my whole life, my pains, my death at its disposal as its foundation.
Jesus is our only foundation.
I place it as a foundation and guard and defense and support.
I will leave out nothing of myself which will not serve to maintain its triumph and
the absolute dominion of my will in full vigor.
So while Louisa is being asked to be the first in the formation of this kingdom, the kingdom
is already formed in Jesus.
He has done absolutely everything, but he doesn't need a creature to enter in and do
it with him.
Just as he's going to tell us in redemption, he did the same thing with his mother, everything
was done completely between the two of them before they made it public.
We're going to read that in a minute.
Therefore don't be surprised if you see the different stages of my age and of my work
being as though repeated in you, the life must be actually repeated in us and you will
see me as a child at one stage or as a young person or even as the crucified or as he has
just noticed both together.
This is the kingdom of my will present in you and therefore all the acts of Jesus are
available and my whole life lines up inside and outside of you.
The result of this is that each one of us must become another Christ and to be another
Christ in the midst of society it means that the Lord can do an enormous amount or that
whole society in which you are present and also the whole world as well because we don't
realize just how much can be done just through one person doing it and look how quietly our
blessed mother lived until she had to go public with the same with us.
This is the kingdom of my will present in you and my whole life lines up inside and outside
of you as guard and defense of my kingdom therefore be attentive and when some fear assails you
and the one that assails her most is that she'll lose Jesus think that you are not alone and
that you have my whole life as help to form this kingdom of mine within you and continue
your flight constantly in the unity of the supreme light of the divine will.
It is there that I await you to give you my surprises in return and to give you more
of my lessons and so on.
Louisa is now being shown that each one of us must actually come to the point of being
transformed in Christ.
That was the Lord's intention from the very beginning.
Let's come to September the 13th 1926 which we're told that the divine being has to be
balanced and Louisa is going to ask a question which is one of our questions is not really
one of her and that is that if the Lord wants to give us the divine will so badly why do
we have to pray for it so insistently that's the way we sing and it's going to explain
that after doing my usual round in the supreme volition I was praying to good Jesus one in
the name of his creation number two in the name of redemption and number three in the
name of the sovereign queen and of everything that she did and suffered the supreme fiat
may be known so that its kingdom may be established with its full strength notice the way she
is able to cluck in to all the acts that were done before her.
This is very important for us that we unite ourselves with all the acts of Jesus all the
acts of our blessed mother all the acts of Louisa and echo and repeat them and through
them pray and did proceed for the church and the world.
Louisa said that she wants to pray in the name of the sovereign queen and of everything
that she did and suffered that the supreme fiat may be known and that its kingdom may
be established with its full triumph and dominion in other words she unites herself with all
of these acts so that she can pray with this power enormous power and the Lord is going
to explain to her and he feels about praying like this that it actually has a huge effect
when you pray like this she says to herself but while doing this I thought to myself if
Jesus himself wants and loves so much that his kingdom be established in the midst of
preachers why does he want one to pray for it with such insistence because after all he
wants it more than we do so we have to understand the dynamic of gift if he wants it he can
give it without so many continuous acts you see that's our question that's the way we
think and my sweet Jesus moving in my interior to obey my daughter my supreme being possesses
the perfect balance that means justice equals mercy justice equals wisdom justice equals
all the other attributes and the reason why I'm saying justice equals is that he's going
to be talking about justice my supreme being possesses the perfect balance and also in
giving my graces and my gifts to creatures perfect balance is required much more so then
for the kingdom of the supreme fiat which is the greatest gift that I had already given
at the beginning of creation and which man rejected with so much gratitude now there you
have the first statement that is being made that the kingdom of the divine will has already
been given to the human race has already been rejected and so if the lord is to reestablish
the kingdom of the divine will he has to sort of know that we want it he wants it but do
we want it in case we would throw it back into his face again does it seem trivial to you
to place a divine will at his disposal with all the goods that it contains and not for
one hour or one day but for his whole life the creator placing his adorable will in the
creature to be able to put his likeness his beauty and his infinities of riches joys and
endless happiness in common he's saying please don't think this is something small this is
something massively great only by possessing our will could the creature acquire the rights
of communion lightness and all the goods of our creator now notice it's in the possession
of the divine will not in just sort of somebody on the way we're talking about the end of
volume 19 now so we're talking about people actually possessing the divine will and he
says it's only when you possess that you acquire the right of communion with god of
lightness and of all the goods of your creator without it there can be no communion with us
that is without possessing the divine will there can be no communion I think if you're
using your own book you should color that hugely because we seem to presume we have communion
let me read it for you again without the divine will there can be no communion with us and
if he takes anything at all it's just our flowerings and the crumbs of our endless goods that
is the explanation it's been given to us in the volumes before now of people living in
the human will even if they are living a virtuous life in the next paragraph then the Lord asks
us to deal with the question do you actually want this badly enough to actually intercede
for it do you want the kingdom of the divine will and all and he's going to tell us and
not in this paragraph but in the following one that the church has been saying they are
father for two thousand years but most people don't seem to give any thought as to how it
could actually happen or become a reality or care okay there is a problem that needs
to be solved so we're going to have to learn to put Luke 11910 into practice and that is
where Jesus taught us to pray with insistence and we have to pray with insistence for the
kingdom of the divine will because the human race is deteriorating at an alarming rate
now with a gift so great happiness so immense a right of divine likeness with the acquisition
of the nobility of our offspring that's Romans 819 which had been rejected do you think it's
something easy that the divine sovereignty without being prayed with no one giving a
thought to receiving this kingdom of the supreme fear that is actually given because if he
gave it nobody would pay any attention it's not thinking about it if they're not trying
to discover how important it is how would they give the response that the lord wants
they wouldn't they pay no attention at all because most people pay no attention to the
our father it would be like repeating the story that took place in the terrestrial even
it could even be worse and besides our justice would be justly opposed to this we would say
our justice would be rightly opposed to this we wouldn't use the same word therefore everything
I have to do the continuous rounds in the supreme volition your incessant prayers for
my will to come and reign your sacrificed life of so many years knowing neither heaven nor
earth directed for the sole purpose of the coming of the kingdom are many props that
I place before my justice first of all I want to give you one a Tesalonians 5 17 where Paul
tells the early Christians to pray without ceasing more all the goods that the lord wants
to give us secondly before I need to read it again I just want to say that Jesus is saying
that God wants to be convinced that somebody actually wants this kingdom enough to intercede
for it you know we might just be leaving it to everybody else to do the intercessions
and notice he said that he kept Louisa sacrificed for so many years knowing neither heaven nor
earth there is an admission on the part of Jesus that actually extremely important because
it explains the terrible pain of the privation that she didn't have the experience of all
the stuff she was going through that she was in fact suffering the most incredible darkness
she was completely cut off from the earth and he said she knew neither heaven nor earth
now that actually is her own description of the privations as well and he said that that
sacrifice that pain that perseverance all of that directed for the sole purpose of the
coming of the kingdom are so many props or supports that I place before my justice that
it may surrender its rights in other words somebody on planet earth wanted the kingdom
of the divine will so badly that she paid for it with her life that's what he's saying
and that all of this evidence becomes the supports that will make the attribute of divine justice
say okay I will surrender and give the rights of the divine will to the human race when
it surrenders its rights it must balance itself with all the other attributes so justice may
find it right for the kingdom of the supreme will be given back to the human generations
there I am trying not to repeat the word just all the time and then so that you would understand
that he said look this is what happened in redemption as well if our justice had not
found the prayers the size the tears the penances of the patriarchs of the prophets and all the
good people of the Old Testament and then a virgin queen who actually possessed the divine
will completely and who took everything to heart with so many insistent prayers taking
upon herself the whole task of the satisfaction of the whole human race he said artists would
never have conceded the descent of the longed for redeemer in the midst of creatures it
would have been inexorable and would have given a cut no to the coming of Jesus on the earth
and when it's about preserving the balance of our divine being he said nothing can be
done there's no way you can get around that here he's saying that it took all of these
prayers acts sufferings and intercessions of the Old Testament and it had to reach a certain
point now we're going to deal with that certain point in the next paragraph and that is he
says it must reach a critical mass they're my words and when it reaches a critical mass
God says to himself enough people on the earth wanted are prepared to intercede are prepared
to sacrifice are prepared to do penance are prepared to give all of their attention to
this for the sake of the rest of the human race so when this critical mass has been achieved
then he will move if you are used to the Old Testament and all the prophets and the timings
of the Old Testament the timing of the coming of Jesus was absolutely awfully precise and
the prophets knew exactly the timing and that's why when Jesus was born old Simeon was looking
for the Messiah because the time was up and that's why the people in Luke chapter 1 became
terribly excited when the angel Gabriel came to Zechariah they said it's time the time
has come they knew the time had come in other words the bank of prayer and suffering of
all the prophets and the saints and the martyrs and our blessed mother most particularly suddenly
it was enough for that incredible gift to be given to us and the same must happen with
the New Testament as well okay so let's come to looking at the critical mass in the next
paragraph who until now has ever prayed with interest with insistence laying down the sacrifice
of one's life that the kingdom of the supreme theater come on the earth she's nobody's done
it Louis is the first it's true that the church has been reciting the our father from the time
I came on the earth which asks thy kingdom come so that my will will be done on earth
as it is in heaven but who thinks about the request that they're actually making it can
be said that the whole importance of such a request remained in my will and that the creatures
recited just to recited without understanding and without any interest in obtaining what
they're reciting in other words many people just pray that prayer as something you pray
they're not actually asking God for his kingdom to come or for his will to be done on earth
in the same way as is done in heaven therefore my daughter everything is hidden a secret while
one lives on the earth and therefore everything seems a mystery that's absolutely true because
when you study the prophets of the Old Testament with all the prophecies that they had which
said so much about the Messiah they still didn't get it when he came we can be confused about
so many things if you take us today we have so much information about the second coming
about the Antichrist and about all the rest of it and yet people act as if they don't
know anything even though they have information about it well it's the same for the Old Testament
times as well while we're on the earth everything is mystery and if anything is known it's so
limited known is that you know it deep within your being not that it's a piece of information
you've collected that man has always something to say about all that I operate in my works
through the veils of creatures the veils of creatures is that the Lord works through the
prophets the priests the martyrs the saints so on and so on the victims soul they reach
the point of saying and why have this good and this knowledge not being given before now
this is typical human beings I mean I don't know how God puts up with us so once they find
out that such a thing has been given which is the situation today you will have people
objecting to this by saying well why do you told this before I mean why do you have to
wait a minute and there have been so many saints before now are you saying that these
saints were no use in eternity Jesus said it's not like that there are no secrets from the
moment you enter eternity you will understand everything because in eternity everything
is actually revealed to you and in eternity you will be shown all things and my works with
justice and how justice could never have given had there not been sufficient acts in the
creature to be able to give what the supreme majesty actually wants to give so that means
that if the critical mass of prayers and intercessions and acts are not done the kingdom of the
divine will is delayed it's actually that simple it's true that everything that the
creature does is my grace that's to Corinthians 12 9 my grace is sufficient for you you don't
need anything else but my grace itself wants to find the prop of the dispositions and the
goodwill of the creature put that into ordinary English what he's saying is we need some cooperation
on your side we need some level of message that you actually want what we're offering
I mean you try and think of a spouse trying to reach out to love their spouse and there's
absolutely no interest shown on the other side totally destroys the thing the Lord wants
the prop of the dispositions on our part and therefore in order to restore the kingdom
of my will upon the earth it requires sufficient number of acts of the creature okay it requires
that and we need to take that on board if you have your own book with you I think you should
market so that my kingdom may not remain in the air it may descend and be formed upon
the very act of the creature and there you have it the kingdom is formed on the acts
of the creature that's why the Lord keeps saying to Louisa keep it up keep your flight
up keep going and we need to understand that as well that the kingdom is actually formed
on the very acts of the creature formed by her to obtain a good that is so great so notice
the decision is on our part to open up and to fuse in the divine will and to do all of
these acts so that the kingdom is formed in us and therefore will be formed through us
so Jesus says to Louisa this is why I push you so much to go around in all our works
and he's doing it all the time both in creation and redemption so that you may place the share
of your acts your I love you your adoration your gratitude your thank you upon all of
our works I call that putting your signature on all his acts many times I've done this
together with you that was to encourage her and then as the fulfillment after your round
with our will comes your refrain now he now gives a little prayer that Louisa says after
her rounds and he says how extraordinarily pleasing it is to him so I want to really
emphasize this prayer and make sure that you're saying it so when she's finished doing her
rounds she says supreme majesty your little daughter comes before you on your paternal
knees to ask you for your fiat your kingdom that has been known by all I ask you for the
triumph of your will that it may dominate and reign overall I'm not the only one who asks
you this but with me are your own works and your own very will therefore in the name of
all I ask I plead for your faith it's most beautiful and perfect prayer and Jesus said
if you knew what a breach in our supreme being that this refrain of yours does you really
hit the target when you pray like that we feel that we are being prayed by all of our
works beseech by our own very will heaven and earth pray on their knees to ask us for the
kingdom of the divine will therefore if you actually want to continue your acts so that
by reaching the established number you may obtain what you love or with so much insistence
here is the Lord telling us that we actually have to persevere and we have to do as many
acts as possible in order for us to put in the number of bricks that were to put into
that new Jerusalem and be part of the building of the kingdom of the divine will so we come
to the last message of volume 19 September the 15th 1926 after writing for four hours
or more I was feeling completely exhausted writing for four hours is not easy and in the
condition that she's in it's very difficult and as I began to pray in his most holy will
according to my usual way my sweet Jesus came out from within my interior and lastly
to himself all tenderness he told me my daughter you are tired rest in my arms what a incredible
invitation to receive rest in my arms how much the kingdom of the supreme fear costs me
and you while at night all the other creatures and then to the break some sleep some enjoy
themselves and some reach the point of actually offending me but for me and for you there's
no rest even at night Sam one two one verse four the Lord neither slumbers nor sleeps and
you are occupied with writing and I with watching over you imparting to you the words and the
teachings that regard the kingdom of the divine will now he has repeated that over and over
and over in volume 19 that he gave her the words and he inspired her and he walked over
her while she was doing it and while I see you right so as to have you do it at length
now I love that because in the early volumes I think you get nearly volume 10 and she's
still resisting absolutely giving anything at length will notice her length increasing
in volume 20 she found it extremely difficult to write everything so he's managed to get
her to write more so while I see you right so as to have you do it at length and not become
tired I sustain you in my arms that you may write what I want and be able to give all
the teachings and the prerogatives the privileges the sanctity and the infinite riches that this
kingdom of mine possesses so Jesus is saying he's the author of this material and if you've
studied enough that you know he is you recognize his voice you recognize his way of doing things
you just recognize his expressions everything if you knew how much I love you and how I delight
in seeing you sacrifice even your sleep and all of yourself for the love of my fear which
so much loves to make itself known in the human generations okay now first of all he says if
you only knew how much I loved you and then he says and how much I delight in seeing you
sacrifice even your sleep now we're living in an overindulged generation we know nothing
really about sacrifice the idea of sacrificing your life in the way that Louisa did and sacrificing
all the pleasures of life and food and drink and relationships and absolutely everything
and also sacrifice her sleep this is martyrdom the real thing with the capital M and seeing
you sacrifice even your sleep I mean this is just love taken to its limits for human
being and all of yourself for love of my fear which so much loves to make itself known to
the human generations it costs us you and me very much it is true my daughter and to repay
you almost always after you have written I let you rest on my heart absolutely extraordinary
that intimacy with God I let you rest on my heart which is overcome with sorrow and with
love now we know why it's overcome with sorrow and with love because God is love and the human
race has given God one big gift and it's called sorrow okay and in all of the reflections
that Louisa gives on the hours of the passion she shows that no matter how much sorrow the
human race gives to Jesus his love goes higher and higher and higher it's really amazing
so I let you rest on my heart which is overcome with sorrow and with love with the sorrow that
my kingdom is not known and also with the love with which I want to make it known so that
in feeling my sorrow and the fire that burns me now in the hours of the passion she continuously
it refers to the fire that burns Jesus you may sacrifice all of yourself so there is Deuteronomy
6 4 to 10 fulfilled and spare yourself nothing for the triumph of my will then Louisa said
while I was in the arms of Jesus the immense light of the divine will that filled heaven
and earth called me to go around in it so that immense light is one Timothy 6 16 God lives
in unapproachable light and one John one five God is light so the divine will call her to
go around in it to have her do her usual acts so that she would give her I love you under
adoration on the whole of creation as she has been describing in the last couple of messages
that it might have the company of its little daughter in each created thing in which it
reigns and dominates now notice that the Lord while being completely and totally and absolutely
and infinitely sufficient unto himself he wants his children around him as Proverbs 8 31 the
Lord delights to be with the children of men okay so that's Proverbs 8 31 he wants her to
be with him and if you go to the gospel of Mark I think it's around chapter 4 with the
calling of the apostles St Mark says that he called them because he wanted them to be
with him he wanted them to be his companions in his ministry so the Lord wants us to be
with him and so Jesus said to our my daughter what light what power what glory an act of
the creature acquires done in my will it told us that many times the light the power the
glory that an act in the divine will receives these act are more than the sun while the sun
remains up high its light eclipses the stars and fills the whole earth bringing its kiss to all
things its heat and its beneficial effect and the light's nature is to diffuse nor does it do any
more work by giving the goods it naturally possesses to those who want them so light is what it gives
light diffuses everywhere and it gives it the acts on in my will are symbolized by the sun so
these acts are now sons he's going to call them as the act is formed my will administers to it the
light to form the sun because only a divine person can make a divine act and so it rises up high
because the sun's nature is to be up high not down below down below means turned towards the earth
involved in the earth otherwise it wouldn't be able to do the good that it does in fact the things
that are down below are always circumscribed individual and limited in time and in space in
other words anything to do with the earth is very limited okay and so if we're only into human
acts then everything is extremely limited they are not nor can they produce universal
goods only the divine act can do that this sun or this act in the divine will formed by my will
and by the act of the creature in rising up high even to the throne of its god forms the true
eclipse it actually eclipses heaven saints and angels there is a revelation and to have
our little acts done in the divine will actually he says the light of them eclipses heaven the
saints and the angels it's totally utterly amazing it is as if the length of its rays would take
control of the earth its beneficial light brings glory joy happiness to heaven and the light of
the truths to the earth it dispels the darkness pain caused by sin and the disillusion of passing
things now notice what the act is doing it's operating in heaven and it's operating on earth
as well it's terribly important for us to realize that we are in fact ministering to all of those
people out on planet earth who have given up their faith and given up god and are turned towards
the earth and towards themselves and many of them turned towards sin as well that we can help them
enormously by these actions the divine will so if you look at the sun in the sky it is
only one object but it's like contains all colors and all effects to give life to the earth in the
same way the act done in the divine will is just one act but it is the son of my will formed in us
is one but its goods and effects are innumerable okay you're talking about one act done in divine
will which is only one divine will but its effects are innumerable and the sun explains that therefore
the kingdom of the supreme fiat will be a kingdom of light and we know this if you go to revelation
22 - because you're told in the book of revelation that the new Jerusalem will not need sunlight because
the lord god himself will be its light so therefore the kingdom of the supreme fiat will be a kingdom
of life a kingdom of glory and of triumph the night of sin will not enter into it that night of sin
will be over and it will always be full day now that's described wonderfully in revelation 22
its refulgent rays will be so penetrating as to triumph from the abyss in which poor humanity has
fallen so these acts because god makes them divine they have divine effects and so while we have
no personal solution to the problems all around us these divine will act god will use them to bring
the solutions it's wonderful it gives you tremendous hope so this is why jesus said i've told you
many times your task is great because i have entrusted to you my divine will the lord is actually
depending on us fusing our will in his and allowing him to turn our acts into divine acts so that he
can do his great work with them so that by making the divine will know you may place its rights and
safety now that's for louisa herself the divine will is so very unknown among the human generations
the goods that will come will be immense and you and i will be twice happy for having worked for the
formation of this kingdom he says so he's talking to louisa there so after this louisa said i was
thinking to myself my beloved jesus says so many admirable things about the kingdom of the supreme
will so holy but nothing of these admirable things seem to show on the outside now here is the final
bit in volume 19 and louisa gives back to him one of our problems we're saying all these wonderful
prayers we're doing these wonderful rounds we're studying we're trying to open up as much as we can
to let the divine will take over we do see any difference we see nothing on the outside you see
there's nothing for the flesh it's totally of the spirit so she says my beloved jesus says so many
admiral things but we don't see anything on the outside if it's tragedies its great goods and
happiness could be seen the face of the earth would change and a pure holy noble blood would flow
in the human veins such as to convert one's nature into sanctity into joy and into perennial
peace that's the transformation we're all looking for so at that moment jesus came out from within
louisa's interior and said my daughter this kingdom of the supreme fiat must first be well
established it must be formed and it must be matured between you and me just as the kingdom of redemption
had been matured between jesus and his mother then it must be transmitted to other people so we're
at this stage of trying to transmit it to other people we're trying to speak about it read it
explain it in so far as we can and try to live it so then where we're at the same happened between
the virgin and me first i was formed within her i grew within her womb i was nourished at her
breast we lived together to form the kingdom of redemption between the two of us one on one as
it no one else existed as he's doing with louisa now and then my very life and the fruits of redemption
which my life itself contained were transmitted to others that's in jesus public ministry and
afterwards so it will be for the supreme fiat first we will do it between the two of us
only one and one and once it is formed i will take care of transmitting it to the rest of humanity
it's easier to have a work come out well when it is formed in private in the hiddenness of the
silence of two persons who really love that work and once it is formed it's easier to manifest it
and to give it as a gift so he said therefore let me do it so what jesus saying is that with the
kingdom of redemption and with the kingdom of the divine will jesus worked the whole thing out
between two people in utter privacy even the neighbors didn't know even the neighbors in
neserith didn't know what was going on and that privacy kept satan completely at bay he couldn't
interfere he couldn't mess it up and so the kingdom is formed completely and totally and
is ready to be handed out as gift and that's what he's done with louisa as well so thank you for
joining me and we will be in volume 20 next week so god bless